[Music]
my name is kelly i am from our dearly
departed and i am a taxidermist and
today i'm going to show you guys how i
restore a taxidermy dog apparently cudi
was a very famous dog in west virginia
she was a dog that lived in a gas
station so everyone knew her
she sat in a window for a very long time
she was sun bleached so she lost all of
her color her ears were broken and she
was missing an eye
so the first step is to basically go
over the animal see what's wrong with it
and i always check and see if there's
any remnants of bugs or a possible
infestation so i'm blowing it with a
vacuum if i don't blow off that dust the
dirt is going to be pushed down into the
fur after i wipe it
cuddy was very fragile fur was coming
out her ears were basically falling off
so certain parts like that you have to
be super careful when cleaning it i just
use rubbing alcohol i don't want to use
too much of it because it can dry out
the animal but it's a really good
cleaner for taxidermy
the black stuff coming off of her head
is paint and i just had to work at it be
super delicate with it because that wire
brush can tear out the hair if you're
not careful
so i was going in circular motions and
kind of just working the paint off and
taking a paper towel wiping it off and
just being super slow with it and really
taking my time
her ears were both cracked this is a
really common thing that can happen with
ears
her ears had to be re-strengthened so
what i first did was i actually
rehydrated them with water i stuffed the
ears with some cotton balls paper towels
just something that would hold the
moisture and wrap them in saran wrap
just kind of keep everything nice and
moist so i could work on it
i let them sit for about a day
sometimes with old taxidermy if you
rehydrate it too much it could actually
fall apart so you really have to watch
that after the ears were rehydrated i
filled it first with clay and i also
filled the ears with bondo that really
strengthened her ears up a lot and then
after her ears were strengthened i went
over top of the bondo with some epoxy
sculpt just to kind of even it out and
fill in those cracks
her one eye was really great looked
awesome but her other eye was missing
when i did
start to clean out what was left of it
there was actually some glass so what i
had to do was actually remove the other
eye that looked okay
because i wasn't able to match the eyes
exactly i couldn't find anything to
replicate it so i didn't want to go in
and put in a different eye that was a
shade lighter again i rehydrated it
removed the other eye and replaced them
with brand new glass eyes i actually
added some more clay into the eye to
give it that extra detail and to make
the eye sit in there really nicely
they were actually bare eyes i believe
because they don't they don't make dog
eyes it was about the same size and
color as a dog
when replacing eyes it definitely is
tricky because it's backwards of how you
would typically do taxidermy so when
you're mounting something fresh those
eyes go on before the skin goes on so
i'm doing it completely backwards and
adding the clay in after the eyes are in
there
she was missing i want to say two or
three of her original nails coyote nails
were about the closest thing i could
find to
dog nails and i just happen to have a
few of them laying around and they work
perfectly
[Music]
after all of her parts are repaired it's
time to airbrush cuddy back to her
original color i choose the airbrush
taxidermy just because it creates a
really nice natural look to them you can
really control how much paint is applied
and you're able to paint really big
areas with a lot of paint very quickly
the paints i used are actually lacquer
paints they're called life tone paints
and they are made for taxidermy animals
they're special colors that are made for
painting skin and replicating those
color tones that are found in animals
with cuddy i was layering those colors a
lot on there i started out with a really
light yellow and some of the darker
colors on her face and i know over with
like a more orangey color to make that
yellow pop out from underneath her fur
what i did for cuddy's muzzle she was
missing for one way to replace fur is to
add flocking i went in with a black and
brown flocking and i mixed it together i
applied it with mod podge so just
typical craft glue
flocking is basically a crushed velvet
material and you're able to spray that
onto the skin and recreate a really
short fur texture and then i painted
over top of that fur again to really tie
it all together and make the colors look
seamless
the tongue was yellow from it being in
the sun i just painted it with acrylic
paints to restore that color
[Music]
taxidermy pieces usually never need to
really be maintained or restored if
they're kept in the right conditions
i've seen pieces that are hundreds of
years old and are in almost perfect
condition generally just dusting pieces
keeping them out of the sunlight
maintaining and making sure that there's
no infestations make these pieces last a
lifetime
[Music]